measures of central tendency are for
example mean median and mode the
arithmetic mean is the sum of all
observations divided by the number of
observations let's look at an example
imagine we have the test scores of five
students 85 90 78 92 and 88 to find a
mean score we add up all the scores and
divide by the number of scor course so
the mean test score of these five
students is
86.6 what about the median when the
values in a data set are arranged in
ascending order the median is the middle
value if there is an odd number of data
points the median is simply the middle
value if there is an even number of data
points the median is the average of the
two middle values
it is important to note that the median
is resistant to extreme values or
outliers let's look at this example no
matter how tall the last person is the
person in the middle Remains the person
in the middle so the median does not
change but if we look at the mean it
does have an effect on how tall the last
person is let's continue with the mode
the mode refers to the value or the
value
that appear most frequently in a data
set a few points to note about the mode
if a data set has one value that appears
more frequently than any other it has
one mode and is called uni modal for
example in the data set 2 3 4 4 5 6 7
the mode is four if a data set has two
values that appear most frequently it
has two modes and is called bu model for
instance in this data set the modes are
four and five of course a data set can
also have more than two modes if it has
multiple values that appear most
frequently it is termed multimodal and
some data sets might not have any
repeating values or the repeating values
all have the same frequency in such
cases the data set has no mode let's
briefly compare measures of central
tendency and measures of dispersion
let's say we measure the blood pressure
of patients measures of central tendency
provide a single value that represents
the entire data set helping to identify
a central value around which data points
tend to Cluster measures of dispersion
like the standard deviation the range
and the interquartile range
indicate how spread out the data points
are whether they are closely packed
around the center or spread far from it
in summary while measures of central
tendency provide a central point of the
data set measures of dispersion describe
how the data set is spread around that
Center I hope you enjoyed the video